yeah it's crazy to think you have all
this structure and all these like things
and contingencies and then it goes oh
actually today yeah just stand on your
roof with a gun and then you get
arrested like what yeah but shouldn't we
lecture some of those Koreans for having
um
[Music]
all right let's talk about it y'all the
cartel lays a Siege on a Mexican city to
after the recapture of the son of El
Chapo that's wild I've been seeing all
these videos
um coming from Mexico and it's crazy
because the cartels
uh the people their Firepower are their
former like Special Forces the former
Navy Seals and stuff so those guys when
the sun got taken they're like okay
we'll just start attacking Federal
buildings and it's like straight up like
military style just boom this post
office being blown up that's like a real
option yeah it's like real Ops and
you're like what the [ __ ] and you it
makes you go thank God our special ops
guys have honor you know what I mean or
they get paid well enough or they get
paid way well enough and they don't turn
on us because if they turned on us would
be so [ __ ] up you've seen people
screaming or running on gas stations and
[ __ ] it's crazy I don't know if they're
still like the big one because you know
how they like different powerful cartels
win right like but the Zetas or
something they were formerly the Mexican
Navy Seals that were trained by the U.S
Navy Seals and they were like catching
all the bad guys and they're just like
wait a minute these drug deers are
making way [ __ ] more than we are as
special ops guys and then they they
became the cartel that's wild what's
crazy is our special ops guys don't even
get paid that much damn but the honor I
think I'm hating I think patriotism is a
huge thing in this country so it helps
like people have like their moral
compass how much do you think those guys
get paid
um once they work for Blackwater quite a
bit yeah when they turn into a mercenary
and that's this that's the incentive
yeah but the thing about it's like
private companies and [ __ ] yeah but the
thing about becoming a mercenary is you
get six figures finally so when you're
not working you're not getting six
figures yeah you know because uh those
the the Mexican special off guys they
were offered way more by the cartel to
work for them
smart that is smart so armed man took
hostages burned vehicles and stormed an
airport in northern Mexico on Thursday
after Federal forces captured ovidio
Guzman one of the World's Most Wanted
cartel leaders and the son of imprisoned
drug lord Joaquin Alexander Guzman
because like sometimes like let's get
the sun it's like what did he do dude so
he's actually in charge yeah he took
over since uh America uh arrested El
Chapo the 33 year old drug boss was
arrested after a pre-dawn gunfight in a
town north of the city of kuliacan I
said that right
um a stronghold of the Guzman Sinaloa
cartel even as the cartel mounted
attacks across the state the Air Force
was able to fly the younger Guzman to
Mexico City said Mexican Secretary of
Defense so like they were able to still
extract him from their city and got into
Mexico City so what blows my mind is
like so El Chapo got caught extradited
right but he's still able to call shots
and people still follow orders even
while he's imprisoned because in like I
would think that if you chop off the
head of the organization then everyone
else would just be like well he's gone
now well if his kid's in charge right
what's his next head right like you take
out the head it's like who's in there so
the kid's in charge but then they pulled
him into jail now right so then the
first time actually in 2019 the kid was
already in charge they did the same
thing they [ __ ] apprehended the Sun
but the cartel responded similarly like
like they just recently did but they
were successful last time it was a
bloody Siege in the same city in 2019. I
think the president said that for public
safety reasons we got to let them out
because all these innocent people were
getting yeah blunch people were getting
[ __ ] but then this time they're just
like nah the crazy thing is whenever I
see the cartel demonstrate the hold they
have on Mexico
it's just so freaking thankful that you
live in this car oh dude for real like
it's next door yeah one of the ones I
recently read it was uh they found
a prison
um where so I guess like when they like
start taking apart the cartel members
they don't disclose which jail he's at
right obviously because then they'll
just go and attack the jail yeah so
they'll like hide and like send people
to different jails somehow this uh the
cartel found out were one of the high
ranking members were at this jail
80 of them showed up and this is one at
least super high security ones all the
guards are like this right it's all
covered they show up and they start just
naming first and last names holy [ __ ]
and then they go if you don't let them
go all of you guys are dead and then the
guys that are like this are like let's
just let them out of here because it's
[ __ ] crazy and then when they go
inside when and then when the final when
the the big authorities come when they
finally go inside they find like [ __ ]
Tempur-Pedic mattresses safes full-on
guns and weapons inside the inside so
somehow all that [ __ ] gets smuggled in
there there's like 50 G's worth of money
it's [ __ ] crazy man so in October
that first time that they tried to take
Usman members of Mexico's newly formed
National Guard rated a luxurious
compound and subdued Guzman
um who was leading some little cartel at
the time but his agents were attempting
to take him into custody hundreds of
Sinaloa Fighters descended on the city
taking hostages blocking intersections
with burning vehicles and laying Siege
to a housing complex for the families of
military personnel oh eight people were
killed families eight people eight
people were killed on that stage back in
20 2009 that phrase is crazy hundreds
descended upon the city yeah that's
crazy there's like cartel loyalists or
probably even people who aren't like
officially part of the cartel that know
to like stand up for the cartel in a
situation like this so that they don't
get [ __ ] later we saw well I mean I
saw this video where there's like a
convoy of cartel armored vehicles with
mounted machine guns just coming in and
just [ __ ] up [ __ ] like it looked like
a real war zone
and I was like dude that's [ __ ] nuts
man it just like makes it really like
shows you how fragile peace in society
truly is it's like their America itself
is barely keeping it together in my
opinion I feel like at any point it
could just all go into chaos or even
when we saw like the crazy riots and
looting and all that stuff it was like
that right right it was like organized
society and then boom [ __ ] REI is
getting destroyed it's like yeah and
it's like the the rooftop
Koreans like for them to go you all are
on your own yeah it's crazy to think you
have all this structure and all these
like things and contingencies and then
it goes oh actually today yeah just
stand on your roof with a gun and then
you get arrested like what yeah but
shouldn't we lecture some of those
Koreans for having guns
and roofs I think we should especially
after what they went through we should
lecture them and and take their guns
away
yeah it's crazy how much of a plan B
there isn't yeah in a lot of government
the uh it says the recapture of Guzman
came days before a scheduled visit to
Mexico by President Biden the first trip
to the country by U.S president since
2014 many speculated that Guzman's
arrest was probably timed in part to
please the Americans who have grumbled
about the efficacy of the Mexican
president's hugs not bullets crime
fighting strategy and his protection of
a former Defense Minister charged by the
U.S prosecutors for collaborating with
organized crime
hugs now I like what I'm hearing yeah
Biden's supposed to go visit there yeah
isn't that crazy
well all this [ __ ] is going down
I mean but that's also another reason
why the U.S is so badass that they're
just like I don't care I'm still going
oh well yeah I mean they'll shut down
four blocks around them like like in L.A
we can't even [ __ ] move anywhere in
L.A if the president's in town it's the
president's wife's in town how do you
even like tell how do you even convince
an entire population of people that used
to be poor until their cartel started
that they should just stop doing that
exactly how do you tell them that like
logically it's like arguing with gang
members it's like they're like cool this
is the only place that ever protected me
ever right right yeah they're like
that's their last line of defense or
their last hope of anything you're like
just don't do that if you come from a
community that don't believe in the
state because the state has always been
making like [ __ ] with you like even
if you think about like um in Appalachia
in those areas right like the
hillbillies they don't even they don't
trust the state because the state always
took their kids the state and and then
you know when they were laborers like
they would work in the factories and
things like that they would exploit them
and they would hire private security to
beat their asses up if they asked for
higher wages things like that so like
every single community that has been
poor and they don't believe I mean like
if you go down to Mexico too everyone
knows that cops are going to pull you
over and extort you so if you can't
trust the the state then it makes it
easy to basically start joining crime
because then you're gonna go with an
organization that's going to just pay
you better hey dude I love lecturing
gang members about how the United States
will have your back you should just
become a responsible voter and then you
watch billions of dollars go to Ukraine
every other week yeah yeah dude for real
every other week it's like okay they're
coming to help you they'll come for you
later they get your crane first then
none of your opinion has any sway yep I
love my country that's why Joe Biden's
going over there he's gonna [ __ ] whip
those guys in a shape he's like why
aren't you guys giving money to Ukraine
huh
what was that was saying saying this but
they were they were like talking about
how uh like life is a criminal like if
that was your only thing that you could
do
logically you are making the right
decision I think so yeah if your whole
family's doing it generationally your
uncle your aunt or whatever it is yeah
it's like it's hard to like for people
to like see the logic of like what why
criminals do what they do it's like well
if they don't do that and they starve or
they have nothing yeah what are they
gonna do why wouldn't you people don't
give them options and then their options
tend to be something that if you look at
just the difference in pay so for
example like let's say uh you're you're
you're a part-time low-level drug dealer
even then you might be making like five
grand a month or something ish right and
then if you do like a x-cons job like
let's say you're you're working at a
butcher shop or maybe you're working
like fast food or something
um what is that
10 bucks an hour
13. you know like yeah like like you
went from making a a x amount of dollars
and you're just like dude like this is
hard
and I'm not used to this and also like
people treat me mean and also like they
don't know how to function in a
in a corporate structure or like in that
type of world where there's a lot of
passive aggressiveness yeah there's a
lot of like political weird [ __ ] like
you know it's like people just taxes
yeah or like the way that people talk to
you like in in a in that kind of
environment it's different like people
can disrespect you a lot and no one
throws fists right so then I think when
you've been in that situation for so
long it's a different culture you're
walking into and then you're just like
man [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm going back to
what I'm used to go back to something
that's what scares me about Mexico is
like they built that up to just
basically be a corporation yeah and
they're winning and you can't get rid of
them and they can buy you now they got
big business it's not like drug dealers
out here nothing like that they got
clean businesses too yeah I think mostly
that's our next War
that we're going to declare the cartels
a terrorist organization no I don't
think so because it's too close there's
no there's no threat to America like so
they're already in America and it's a
business organization versus a political
or cultural like so it's like so for
example right like because those burning
cars are starting to arrive in San Diego
and stuff but we got too many voters
here you know what I mean there has just
never been a War on Drugs that was
winnable but I think the thing is
there's a lot of people that profit from
the war on drugs and it's main it's like
maintainable so like once it gets to the
point where they're [ __ ] up Americans
like innocent lives not gang members
like if they're killing
people in the community then things will
get like tightened up but they're not
gonna stop they can't ever stop the drug
sales and Drug
organizations and what I meant on the
voters thing is like imagine being like
hey we got to vote for this War on Drugs
and then like cartel takes like all the
Hispanic people's like uh families
hostages that are still in Mexico like
vote against it you know what I mean
it's like we have to we have so many of
the Hispanic diaspora just like in
America as well I think like with
relatives with like the cartel
specifically in Mexico would be
it would be like Civil War yeah because
it's just it's just it's a scary thought
because it's right next door
but the money's made here yeah yeah you
know like all of the funneling is the
drugs come here and the money's made
here and they bring the money back yeah
which is why it's symbiotic versus like
that's why I think that it won't be uh
that bad because the cartel needs U.S to
purchase yeah and also if you think
about places like Tulum and where they
like Cancun and where the cartel is
invested in it's safer than the rest of
Mexico I really think it'll never happen
because it's too corrupted on both sides
yeah I think you you'd be fighting your
own organization and there's no there's
no end game as in like so when the U.S
goes into
um a lot of other countries to go to war
right there's an end game of either
profiteering or some type of goal
achieved whereas like here I don't
really see where the winning like what
what they were going to achieve
unless it's like one of those kind of
like a usurp thing where like they'll
mask it as war against drugs but really
they're just trying to do a regime Bingo
yeah if look if Mexico ever started to
act against U.S interests then we would
absolutely go to war yeah that's what I
mean by it's not affecting the income or
it's not yeah but it's not a War on
Drugs it's more like they're just a
hostile takeover and now cartels are
American and it's not just one cartel
too this is my my thing is that it's not
just one cartel they're all fighting
amongst each other so different heads of
the snake would just keep popping out
right and it's just different
organizations so as long as one group is
not like the Taliban that takes over
everything then it's just gonna continue
yeah and we're just realistically sewing
the dark about whatever their whole
thing is like there's no way that we
know we don't even know what our own
government does let alone what something
like that is really planning at the top
yeah we don't even know how to do the
case and we need the cartel stuff
because if we don't have [ __ ] crazy
cartel Generations We're not gonna have
crazy sick Netflix shows you know we
monetize off of other people suffering
so well in this country if we did know
about JFK though think about the
ramifications of that part like now you
know all these people who were
um working at the time to cover up for
JFK we would know what their names are
and that would be horrible didn't they
just come out with the CIA uh there's
actual involvement with the CIA with the
JFK just came out and then people just
glossed over it yeah we don't know right
we don't they did gloss over it we know
what was missing like these are Pages
missing from what they have released and
what they haven't released is like why
are you withholding this it's so weird
and then there's a leak about it
potentially right so it's not like a
saying there's a source but there's a
source saying they didn't name them
though it's be it's because they were
involved
yeah redacted Lisa are so funny it's
like all right fine we'll give you the
information and then you like cut out
90. it's not it's not explicitly stated
but it's like enough to be able to draw
that narrative and look they've worked
us like this our whole lives where we
all laugh about the redactions now we
don't actually take it seriously as a
populist We There is a them versus us
going on and they openly admitted we
don't represent you we're doing this for
ourselves [ __ ] like we are
self-preserving right now and so we all
see these huge document dumps with all
these redactions and you see people on
news on TV laughing about it because
we're all so [ __ ] used to it yeah
like we're not supposed to have
authority over government institutions
they have authority over you that's
where I feel like can be shaky as when
we go back to the conversation of like
um if the citizens don't trust the state
right like if there's no sense of like
community and like I believe in the
organization in the institution that I'm
a part of then what's going to happen is
Mexico 2.0 might be California 2.0
don't say that beautiful beaches ah
beautiful woman
[Music]